bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors 30 millions de primo
vacciner la france est en train
d'atteindre son objectif c'est en tout
cas la première chose à noter
aujourd'hui
oui effectivement et c'est important
parce que c'est avec ça que l'on sortira
de la crise il n'ya pas ya pas de
mystère il y a que le vaccin qui nous
permettra de penser de de se comporter
différemment que de la façon dont se
comporte depuis maintenant un peu plus
d'un donc oui le max 1 c'est la façon de
s'en sortir et le fait qu' il ya une
bonne adhésion de la population est une
très très bonne nouvelle si l'on se
réfère au nombre de premières doses
administrées quotidiennement et bien on
se rend compte 1 qu'il y ait un léger
ralentissement est ce que la france est
en train d'atteindre le plafond dans sa
campagne vaccinale
alors ça j'en sais rien parce que pour
se voir c'était un plafond il faudra
être après plafond donc je ne sais pas
il ya sans doute de multiples facteurs
qui expliquent ce ralentissement le
premier d'entre eux on arrive maintenant
à vers les populations qui étaient les
plus hésitante voire les plus
réfractaires donc cela il va falloir
faire preuve de pédagogie pour essayer
de les convaincre
la deuxième raison c'est que battre tout
le monde y est juste raison le nombre de
cas est en train de diminuer
et donc la tentation est sans doute de
se dire pourquoi laisser plus la peine
de me faire vacciner puisque la maladie
n'existe plus ce qu'il faut mais
l'apparence est là et puis il ya aussi
sans doute un calcul beaucoup plus
trivial qui est de se dire oui mais si
je me vaccine maintenant ma deuxième
dose elle sera pendant mes vacances donc
là ça va être un problème pour moi et je
vais repoussé pour vacciner après les
vacances après mon retour de vacances
donc tout ça doit sans doute être un
petit peu
mêlée pour pour expliquer ce
ralentissement alors est comment on
n'existait que le chili qui affiche
aujourd'hui un des meilleurs taux au
monde quant à sa vaccination 45% des
finiens sont aujourd'hui vacciner comme
on explique pourtant la région de
santiago a été confiné aujourd'hui alors
ça je suis pas du tout spécialiste de
l'épidémiologie au chili donc je peux
vraiment pas vous dire quelque chose
le d'intelligent là dessus on peut on
peut imaginer qu'il a eu la variante qui
est qui est intervenu c'est possible
mais d'un autre côté il faut aussi se
méfier de des chiffres c'est à dire
qu'on vous dit 45 % des gens vaccinés
avec une première dose
mais ça ne veut pas dire immunisés
puisqu'on est une unité dix jours après
la deuxième dose donc il n'ya il faut
relativiser certainement les chiffres et
entre la première et la deuxième dose ya
de la place pour des pour des
contaminations
donc c'est peut-être aussi une des
explications et pour revenir au cas
français on avait des images hier de
cette fête géante ans avec plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui se sont
rassemblées sans application des gestes
barrières
est-ce que son jeter la pierre à
personne mais évidemment est ce que les
français sont en train de baisser un peu
la garde
ah bah oui quand on raconte mon retard
ce qui est totalement irresponsable et
il faut appeler les choses comme elles
sont c'est irresponsable
mais c'est avec ce genre de
fortement qu'on permet au virus de
continuer à circuler de continuer à
affecter des personnes ne contienne et
minou continuer à affecter des personnes
fragiles puisque toutes les personnes
fragiles ne sont pas vaccinés et c'est
ce qui peut conduire éventuellement à
nouveau des mesures restrictives c'est à
dire si les restaurants ferment à
nouveau mais ça va être à cause de ce
genre de comportement donc c'est là où
je dis il ya une irresponsabilité
vis-à-vis du fonctionnement collectif
qui est qui et à chasser désolante
vous n'avez pas de boule de cristal un
sens vous prêter des talents de
visionnaire
est-ce que son nouveau si la vaccination
continue à un rythme assez élevé est ce
qu'un retour à la normale pourrait être
envisagée d'ici quelques mois
mais bien sûr bien sûr mais tout soutien
dans la vaccination est là et entend
l'immunité dite collective le respect de
mesures minimales et de bon sens si ça
et si le chiffre de vaccination est
atteint a essayé les mesures sont
respectées oui bien sûr on pourra
retrouver une vie normale mais c'est
seulement à cette condition
c'est pas par l'opération d'une espèce
de mairie et qui tout d'un coup dirait
ou virus va temps je veux plus te voir
non c'est pas du tout ça c'est vraiment
nous qui avons en main notre destin
jean paul stahl merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
infectiologues au chu de grenoble alpes
merci à